bonjour umberto giovanni merci merci
beaucoup d'être en direct ce matin sur
rtl france alors cette mesure
controversée qui concerne certaines
régions en italie d'administrer le
vaccin astrazeneca
pendant ces journées portes ouvertes
qu'en pensez vous alors bon déjà il faut
dire que c'est une nouvelle toute
fraîche mais ces antennes d'ailleurs
très jeune car me nice ont été suspendus
but les déchets du risque mais toujours
présente que d'une thrombose surtout
chez les jeunes femmes donc disons qui
au départ c'était sûr qu'il y avait une
campagne vaccinale italie en coin france
les dpi sont allé défaire sénégal sur le
campagne vaccinale qui hélas démarré
très doucement et du coup la sté l'idée
pour atteindre cet objectif d imiter
collective les 70 % avant l'été mais
forcément certains régions utile et il y
avait des post hoc deux cousines cas ils
ont pensé d'organiser et des open days
il faut dire d'un côté les jeunes et ont
bien répondu à cette demande
je pense qu à l'italie si on était
beaucoup plus traumatisées qu'en france
la jeune population parce qu'il faut
dire que l'habitat tic à distance pour
l'école a duré presque toute l'année
scolaire
mais l'université c'était qui la
distingue donc les jeunes ils ont très
envie des sorties dvi d contact mobile
et social les vaccine in italy et s'est
fait passé comme les les allèles passage
obligé pour pouvoir obtenir 5 et donc
astra zeneca scène très controversée in
italy maintenant il est dédié aux plus
de 60 ans mais après chaque région
certaine autonomie dans le choix et les
problèmes c'est qu'ils ont vraiment
l'impression qu'il en a fait sa belle
pour couler les doses
jackson qui était dans le frigo et qui
ne savent pas quoi faire parce que
beaucoup de monde bien mood pour dire
aussi qu'elle italie par rapport la
transcende les pages sur le vaccin qui
est ce mini très bien ça ce que vous
allez dans votre centre
vous avez votre vaccin du coup là ce que
commande une occasion pour choisir vos
culs en france ça dépend du lieu où fait
vacciner en tout cas le vaccin
astrazeneca est interdit pour l'instant
en tout cas où au moins de 60 ans est ce
qu'il ya eu du répondant vous disiez
c'est open days est ce qu'elles ont déjà
est ce que ces journées portes ouvertes
ont eu lieu déjà et est ce qu'elles ont
remporté du succès ou pas dans les
régions qu'ils le font effectivement ils
ont eu lieu et comme je le disais les
jeunes est heureux et il se serait pendu
c'était presque comme un comme un
concert dans un stade de grains stars du
rock comme une finale de la champion's
league il ya beaucoup de monde qui
voulait y aller parce que l italie broom
un glacis finissage qui est laid back
scène ça va permettre de retourner un
bide avant du coup les jeunes qui ont
été les plus pénalisées par cette
restriction tout cas ils ont émis des
retraites leur vider la boîte de nuit et
tout ça est et on leur dit si vous
faites maxi néoprène halemba demi donc
qu'ils vont donc la polémique c'est que
d'un côté on a fait miroiter une sortie
des crises mais simplement spécifié
journellement les risques bénéfices et
aujourd'hui on arrête parce qu'on sait
que même si le risque est très faible
par rapport aux bénéfices les faire se
faire vacciner
c'est très important les jeunes ici son
bac ce n'est pas pour eux mais surtout
pour qu'elle a suscitée puisse reprendre
une vie normale je sais pas si vous êtes
et pour pouvoir aussi peut-être partir
en europe puisque c'est aussi une des
principales motivations des jeunes pour
pouvoir bouger en europe en tant que
médecin est ce que vous pensez que c'est
justifié cette crainte de thrombose on
voit qu'au royaume uni
la plupart de la population a été
vaccinée à l'astra zeneca moi je trouve
que tu as le médecin et jeu
vécu moi-même catch et les milliers
d'actionnaires les médecins qui sont
députés à la vaccination
ils sont plus trop de médecins
fonctionnaires dont qualité là on fait
de la grosse amalgame alors qu'elle est
mais parce qu'elle est partie sur un
bataille derrière maxime tout le monde
ce trading a forcément on peut aussi les
somistes celle des personnes jeunes mais
il faut faire de la médecine il faut
faire un d interrogatoire médical savoir
les facteurs de risque par exemple les
limiter à des femmes un jeune déjà une
femme qui fume et qui prend la pilule on
sait déjà qu'il ya une côte et rembotte
et des personnes qu'ils ont des
familiarités pour la thrombose mais
c'est pas forcément de tous les jeunes
qui fait pas la doire voyais dedans
comme chance et c'est comme que la
médecine
le problème de ces open days c'est
peut-être qu'il n'y pas eu de
consultation médicale au préalable non
il était vraiment eu dix c'était un peu
la performance d'arriver à vacciner et
tout le monde très rapidement mais c'est
très bien que ça c'est pas de la famille
tine ça c'est jusque dans les campagnes
plus médiatique qu'elle est médicale
dans la routine on interroge les
patients on évalue les risques bénéfices
et chaque personne est différente
la perdrix côté humaniste de la médecine
depuis longtemps est ce qu'on sait
combien de doses ont pu partir grâce à
ces open days
alors ça moi je n'ai pas les chiffres
exacts je sais qu'il est le plus de
succès il a eu 8000 personnes qui ont
été vaccinées dans la journée mais ç'a
permis de poursuivre la campagne
vaccinale avec les objectifs qu'ils sont
mais voudrait par les ministères civils
et de 8,6 les otages et d'avoir 70 % des
relations vacciner avant la fin du mois
de juillet polémique
si on part en vacances sur la droite va
signer dans une autre région qui est la
propre à leur poulain nord mais on vit
dans des cas exceptionnels entre le
faire parce qu'il ya aussi mineur et
commencer les vacances
la première dose et où ils vont faire la
deuxième est donc pas rentré de deux
cases profit de windows
je vais vous poser comme question est-ce
que ça a créé un appel d'air puisque
certaines régions l'interdisent 7,7 cet
événement d'open days est ce que des
personnes d'une certaine région sont
partis dans d'autres régions pour se
faire vacciner
non c'est pour lui maintenant parce que
je vous dirai pas le faire vacciner dans
notre région il faut savoir que la
politique sanitaire en italie il est
très régionalisé par rapport à une
politique nationale in italy chalonnes
il a beaucoup d'autonomie sur la
décision des synthèses donc l'état à lui
une baguette sénégalais après chaque
légende même dans la cuvette sharks
départ du kobus sa manière merci
beaucoup mais retour du roi ni de nous
avoir répondu en direct ce matin dans la
matinale de rtl france